Borderlands threes next expansion is
called guns love and tentacles and it's
got a whole bunch of content set on a
brand new planet here's everything you
need to know about your visit as I lower
gas is an ice planet and it's home to
some new species of enemies you'll fight
rock slugs wolven and cultists with
crazy powers as you shoot them down
you'll of course be picking up new guns
hunter skins room decorations and other
loot you're visiting zile our ghosts for
the wedding of sir hammerlock and
Wainwright Jacobs Borderlands twos
gauged the mech romancer just so happens
to be their wedding planner so you'll be
fighting alongside her in this DLC
there's also a lodge owner named Mann
cubis who's totally not a secret bad guy
you'll have to grab guns love and
tentacles to experience that new content
but the DLC does come alongside an
update for all borderlands 3 players
first and foremost this update increases
the game's level cap from 53 to 57 that
bump means you can use an extra skill
point to gain a second capstone skill
which totally changes the dynamics of
high-level play gearbox says it's a
quote huge surge of power for endgame
players that said all the quests and
enemies on zile argost's scale to your
level no matter what in fact you can
create a new vault hunter and skip right
to the new content if you want to guns
love and tentacles is the second of four
planned expansions for Borderlands 3 and
you get all four of them via the game
season pass that'll cost you 50 US
dollars or 40 pounds the DLC drops with
the aforementioned update so stay tuned
to game spot for full patch notes you
can check out some new gameplay from the
expansion in the meantime
[Music]
you